hello everyone welcome today's live
broadcast using the network architecture
of expression quantitative loke trait
loci to understand complex traits I'm
Bob Woodruff lab root so i'll be your
moderator for today's event before we
begin i have a couple of important
announcements this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to submit questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them into
the Q&A window which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
you can increase the size of the slide
enlarge the slides by clicking on the
screen icon on the lower right-hand side
of this slide window if you experience
problems during the event with audio or
visual please click on the support
button at the top right hand corner of
the presentation window now I'd like to
announce our speaker for today dr. John
Platt egg dr. platicas postdoctoral
research fellow at the dana-farber
cancer institute please join me in
welcoming dr. platic I will now turn the
presentation over to him all right well
thanks Bob so today I'd like to talk
about using the network architecture of
eqtls to understand complex traits and
if you caught John Quackenbush is talk
earlier today he alluded to it a little
bit and I think that this talk fits into
sort of a larger body of work that the
Quackenbush lab is currently doing in
trying to understand some of these big
data questions by using network
techniques and specifically you know won
one challenge that we always run into is
that we get a network and then now what
you know you can you can make a hairball
but then trying to extract useful
biological information out of that can
be a challenge so hopefully I'll provide
some some ideas for that today
specifically in the context of
to TLS so I'd like to first acknowledge
my collaborators Peter Castaldi and Don
de Mayo who are both faculty at the
harvard medical school and brigham and
women's hospital and then of course my
advisor John Quackenbush so before I get
too far ahead of myself and outline for
the talk I'll discuss a little bit some
of the challenges from going from G
wasps to function genome-wide
Association studies and then talk a
little bit about calculating eqtls then
finally our attempts at modeling eqtls
as bipartite networks and then finally
trying to go from network properties to
biology which you know as someone who's
worked on gene regulatory networks
before and coming from a network physics
background I think that's probably the
most challenging aspect of some of these
problems which is what aspects of the
network topology are actually most
informative to the biology of the data
that you're working with and then
finally I'll discuss some future
directions that we have for some of this
eqtl analysis so earlier this year there
was a paper that came out in nature
talking about the body mass index and
the genetic contribution to that and so
this method or this paper rather used
three hundred and thirty-nine thousand
individuals and their genotypes and what
I think is particularly illuminating is
that the 97 low side that they found
accounted for only two point seven
percent of the BMI variation and the
genome-wide estimates suggest that the
common variation accounts for twenty
percent of BMI variations so you have
lots of these low side these these snips
that all appear to have weak effects and
there's another paper that came out in
October of last year looking at the
genetic contribution and genetic
variation in human height and you know
in this in this particular paper they
used a quarter million individuals
253,000 and they were able to find 690
seven variants that were able to explain
twenty percent of the phenotypic
variance but then to go to twenty one
percent they needed two thousand roughly
snips to get twenty four percent of the
variance yet they include 3,700 snips
and then to get up to twenty nine
percent of the phenotypic variance you
needed 9,500 snips so clearly the snips
that are associated with these these
phenotypes these complex traits there's
not just one that's driving the complex
trait many of these are not strongly
Mendelian but rather you have this large
group of snips that appear to be at
least associated with phenotypic
variance so you know in case you're not
already familiar with G wash genome-wide
Association studies aim to associate a
genetic variant usually a snip with a
trait and typically at a genome-wide
significance level meaning that the
p-value has to be less than 10 to the
minus 8 and so this is from a paper in
2013 but genome-wide Association studies
have identified more than 8,500
significant associations with more than
350 complex traits and you know that
these numbers are exploding as as more
data becomes available but the challenge
with these methods is that you go from a
single nucleotide polymorphism or single
variant to a cell or tissue organ level
trait and so how does how do you bridge
this this gap functionally because
eighty-eight percent of the snips and
the nhgri gos catalog are intronic or
energetic so they're not directly
affecting coding and in fact there's a
paper that came out from the gtex
consortium just last week that suggested
that number is more like ninety-five
percent of snips so the the issue then
it's you know where is the function when
you want to investigate this
biologically and so what people often do
is end in this gtx paper that came out
last week which i would highly recommend
reading
they took an expression approach so
instead of just looking at whether or
not the snip is associated with the
complex trait you can do an association
with a snip and then a jeans expression
level using gene expression and Geney
genotyping from a matched set of samples
and so typically what's done is looking
only at snips that are within a certain
window of the transcriptional start site
so a common choice is a plus or minus
one mega base around the transcriptional
start site and so then you take a
particular snip you look at the gene
expression for the gene and then you can
do some sort of usually a linear
regression between the allele frequency
of the locus and the expression level
and so one of the other reasons that
dumb that people focus on sis is that
these effects are often easier to
interpret biologically and they have
strong effects and so you're for example
you're looking here at a figure from
trends and genetics from Gilla at all in
2008 and the left panel here is showing
each blue dot is a snip in its position
from the transcriptional start site of
the hla-c gene and the y-axis is the
minus log of the p-value for the
association between the gene expression
for hla-c and the sniff presents the
snip dosage and so the red dot and the
left panel the one with the minus log p
value close to 11 there 12 you can see
the genotype versus the expression in
the right-hand panel for that and so you
can see that you know this is kind of a
canonical example of an eqtl where the
expression changes as a function of the
genotype in a linear fashion however
there have been a couple of papers in
the last year year and a half especially
looking at this concept of trans eqtls
which are those that are outside of this
window
the transcriptional start site and
there's some work suggesting that trans
eqtls and more salts type specific they
can be associated with many genes so you
can imagine you know one example of a
trans eqtl might be one where there's
the snip is located in the promoter
region of a gene that is a transcription
factor and it alters the expression of
that transcription factor and thus all
of the downstream targets of that
transcription factor are also affected
and so there was a nature genetics paper
that came out in October of last year
looking at these trans eqtls and two
very large cohorts where I think the
first one is five roughly 5,000
individuals of 5000 samples and the
replication cohort was on the order of
3000 and they found that these trans
eqtls many of them were replicated so
there there does seem to be to be
evidence that they exist and in addition
there was a paper that also came out
recently from Karl King's words group
showing that if you look at these trans
eqtls which may in the genomic sense be
far away they may actually physically be
very close and so if you this paper
looked at higher order chromatin domains
using hi-c data and found that there's
actually a very sort of rich structure
to eqtls when you include the proximity
based on these high see domains so
something that might seem far away
genomically is actually physically very
close so there's a I think there's some
good evidence to to suggest that trans
eqtls are biologically relevant and
interesting but one of the additional
problems with these is the computational
challenge so for example for some of the
data that will show later if you have
roughly a million and a half snips and
20 and gene expression for 23,000 genes
that's a huge number of Association
tests if you want to look at all
possible snip gene pairs and in fact um
you know this would take roughly
eight hours to run on one of the
clusters here at dana-farber so you know
it's it's very very intensive however
there was a paper that also came out
last year by Andres oblong and he
provided this package in are called
matrix eqtl which is a very nifty way to
do lots of eqtl analysis via large
matrix operations and as we use that for
this project and found that it's
actually very easy to use and I'd highly
recommend it and so this is a screencap
from his website and you can see there's
a little quote from a satisfied customer
from King's College London saying that
you know this just shorten my computing
time from a year to a couple of days and
so this really opens up the ease of
calculating many many eqtls but we think
that that this is a reasonable way to go
as well because what this is going to do
is then produce many snips connected to
many genes and I think this speaks to
our intuition about how genetic variants
affect complex disease which is that you
know with the exception of the highly
penetrant Mendelian diseases when we're
thinking about complex disease that
especially ones that are age-related or
are late onset you know these things are
the are being influenced by many snips
that are then you know potentially of
weak effect as in the case of the G
wasps associations you have thousands of
snips that are then influencing genes
regine regulation and cell function and
so as someone from a networks background
my intuition when I get data like this
is to then try to treat all of these
these eqtls as a network of links
between snips and jeans and specifically
this naturally forms a bipartite Network
which is just to say that your network
has two classes of nodes you have snips
and jeans and you only ever have links
that go between the two different
classes of nodes so you only ever have
links between snips and jeans
you don't have links between snips and
snips or genes and genes I will say that
you could consider extending this work
and drawing links between the snips if
you have epistatic interactions for
example or if you wanted to put gene
regulatory links between the genes if
one of your genes is a transcription
factor for example and you want to
include its targets but that's not work
that will consider here so briefly the
the data set that we use to create this
bipartite network we got it from the
lung genomics research consortium and
the the website for that you can see at
the bottom of the slide here and this is
a collection of lung tissue from of
samples using it with COPD and also
control COPD is chronic obstructive
pulmonary disease and I'll discuss the
disease on the next slide briefly here
but you can see that we have a mix we'll
need to when we do the Qt l's correct
for smoking as as most of the the lung
tissue came from individuals of a
smoking history and this gold stage you
see on the rightmost column is just a
clinical marker of disease severity and
it has to do with a marker of pulmonary
function and so you can see that we have
a broad spectrum of gold stages as
they're called and so COPD as I
mentioned is chronic obstructive
pulmonary disease and it is the third
leading cause of death in the United
States and it's common sub types which
are perhaps better known our emphysema
and chronic bronchitis and the disease
has a very strong environmental
component which is that cigarette smoke
is the leading cause of COPD however you
know from a genetics perspective the
interesting part is that uh you know one
estimate has it that only twenty-five
percent of smokers who did not
previously have COPD before smoking go
on to get it so not everyone who smokes
gets COPD so this is the data set that
we're using for the eqtl
calculation we used matrix eqtl we
controlled for age sex and Packers we
looked only at the genotype snips we did
not impute and we excluded snips that
had a minor allele frequency less than
five percent and then after that we use
matrix eqtl to consider all possible
snip gene pairs so I sort of outline
then of how we construct our network we
take a snip and gene and then we perform
the linear regression using matrix eqtl
and then if the result of that test
after doing all tests and doing an FDR
correction persists and trans separately
but both holding them to an FDR ten
percent if the snip and the gene have an
association that is then has an FDR less
than ten percent we consider it to be a
link in our network so we draw a line
between that snip and that gene and we
do that for all of our genes a knowledge
that all of our snips and then we wind
up with this network and so as sort of a
first test of what the network
properties looked like we investigated
the degree distribution and so because
this is a bipartite network we actually
have two degree distributions to
consider and if you're not familiar with
some of the sort of network science
parlance the degree is just the number
of links that a node has and so what
you're looking at here is just the
essentially the normalized histogram or
the frequency of nodes that have a given
degree so for the snip degree
distribution and these are both plotted
on on log log axes you can see that on
the left hand side here for the snip
degree distribution that the
overwhelming majority of the snips are
only connected to one gene so that's the
sort of upper left-hand corner of this
plot however you can see that there are
a few there are a few genes that have
a decent number of connections and so
you can I try to use the pointer here in
the sort of the right side of the plot
you can see there are a handful that are
connected to many genes and then we see
a similar sort of sort of distribution
for the genes and so I should mention
also that this entire network includes
about 30,000 snips and 3,400 genes so
what we what we wanted to do next is ask
whether or not this these distributions
were power-law distributed there's a lot
of literature suggesting that many
networks in the real world so
sociological networks technical networks
and biological networks have this
so-called power law degree distribution
and one of the reasons that people like
to talk about it is because these power
law degree distributions networks that
have those have these hubs and so the
idea is that if if a network has this
kind of distribution they're susceptible
to a targeted attack of one of the hubs
so you could imagine that if you removed
one of these nodes that's connected to
20 or 30 or 40 different genes that it
would significantly impact negatively
the connectivity of the network and so
the popular example in technological
networks is air transport for example
here in the United States if you were to
remove O'Hare Airport in Chicago you
would significantly impact the success
of air travel in the United States so
what we wanted to do is actually test
whether or not so they these
distributions were power law distributed
and oftentimes if you just look at them
if you were to plot for example this a
true power law distribution where the
probability that a node has a degree of
has degree X goes like X to the minus
alpha if you were to plot that on top of
this you could get a fit that looks
pretty good but because you're you're in
the log
space small distances can actually be
quite large so we used a method outlined
in a paper by Mark Newman Aaron closet
and cosmic shalizi which I highly
recommend as well which is called power
law distributions in empirical data and
they have a very principled way for
trying to determine whether or not your
distribution is power law distributed
and so the advantage there is that you
do the fit so you take your empirical
distribution and then you try to fit a
power law to it you estimate what the
exponent for the power law is and the
minimum degree at which your power law
activity begins and then you do a
randomization where you generate in this
case five thousand synthetic data sets
that have those parameters then you try
to fit a power law distribution on top
of that and ask how much better that fit
is and the advantage to this is that you
can get a p-value for rejecting the
power-law hypothesis so a p-value that
says you know how confident am i that
this distribution is not a powerful and
so it turns out actually despite looking
very power law distributed it is not the
snip distribution is not power law
distributed the genes so the p-value
here is is almost zero meaning that
we're very calm or fire it we're fairly
confident that we can reject the
power-law hypothesis it's a little bit
unclear for the gene distribution since
the p-value is hovering around point one
but regardless there do seem to be these
hubs in the network and so what we
wanted to know then was where the jiwa
snips in terms of the degree are these
the global hubs in the network are they
the ones that seem to be most connected
to all of these genes and it turns out
that that is not the case so what you're
looking at here is is the gene degree
distribution that I showed you before
but the red dots here are the is the
distribution for the jiwa snips that we
pulled in from the nhgri g wasps catalog
and so
what you can see is that for each of
these degrees the jiwa snips do seem to
be more highly connected for the low
degree so there are fewer jiwa snips
there's a lower fraction of jiwa snips
rather that have degree 1 compared to
the entire network however there's this
sort of desert in the right side of the
plot where all of our global network
hubs the eqt the snips associated with
many genes those are not jiwa snips so
we found this somewhat surprising
especially given the sort of global hub
hypothesis in in biology however when we
thought about it we think it makes a lot
of sense and it brought back remembrance
of a story from from World War 2 where
the British Air Force was trying to
figure out they had a limited amount of
armor that they could put on their
bombers and they are trying to figure
out the best place to do that and so
I'll give you a second and encourage you
to try to think if you're handed this
picture where you would want to put the
additional armor and so a statistician
in Britain at the time was handed this
but he was also handed this information
which were the bullet holes on all of
the planes that returned back from
bombing runs and so he looked at the
data and thought about it for a little
while and realized that it was pretty
obvious which is that you should put the
armor where the bullets are not because
those areas are if you look at the
picture here you can see that it's the
cockpit and the engines really where
there are no bullet holes and the reason
for that is because those planes are not
coming back that a bullet hole to those
areas is so damaging that the plane
almost should you know does not come
back from its mission and we think that
this is a good analogy for the jiwa
snips in the context of our eqtl network
if there's a Jia snip that if there's a
snip in general that is so deleterious
that it's disrupting hundreds of genes
for example then that's probably going
to disrupt the self-sufficiently that
it's not going to live long enough to to
divide and that it's going to die and
we'll never observe
and so we're we've come to think of the
jiwa snip says this sort of bullet holes
in the the returning bombers so if if
the the global degree is not the most
informative measure then we kind of took
a step back and ask well you know can we
use this network to infer something
useful about the function of these snips
if they're you know if our are easy
hypothesis which is that they're the
global drivers isn't true and so what we
wanted to hypothesize is that maybe it's
the groups of snips that are affecting
groups of genes to influence function
that it's really you know there's
there's not just one or two snips that
are driving this as you know even though
that might be easier to work with that's
not really what's going on it's more
this many-to-many connection and so what
we decided to do is we tried clustering
the nodes in the bipartite network into
communities based on the network
structure and so this there's a rich
history in in statistical physics and
network physics on community structure
analysis and communities are just groups
of highly interconnected nodes and so
these community structure algorithms
what they try to do is put nodes
together in a group such that the number
of links within a community or a group
is higher than expected by chance and
I'll go into that expected by chance bit
here in a minute but it's sort of a if I
explain it show you this picture it kind
of makes sense intuitively which is that
you have this network in the lower right
here and these gray blobs represent the
different communities and so you want to
make sure that you divide things up so
that there are lots of links within the
gray blobs and very few links going
between them and formally what these
community structure algorithms typically
do is they assign nodes to communities
such that the modularity queue is
maximized and so the modularity is just
a sum over all of the communities where
you take the fraction of network links
in community I and so
track that from the fraction of links
you would expect by chance and that
expected by chance uses the degree
distribution of the network that you
have one of the other advantages to
these community structure methods is
that unlike some clustering algorithms
you do not have to give it the number of
clusters a priori so that is one of the
things that it attempts to find and you
can imagine that that this might make
sense in a biological context you can
imagine that there might be a group
pathways that are have many links within
the pathway but they only have a few
coming in or going out and this is sort
of our vision of what these communities
might represent so one thing that we did
have to modify though from the
traditional community detection is that
we had a pipe we have a bipartite
network and so we always expect that
snips are never going to be connected to
other snips and that genes are all are
never going to be connected with other
genes and so our bipartite community
picture might look a little more like
something in the middle of the slide
here where you have groups of snips that
are the circles they may have lots of
links to the same set of genes but not
very many links to other sets of genes
and so we need a different null model
that accounts for that and I'll sort of
go briefly through this slide since it's
somewhat mathematical but I would refer
you to the paper by michael barber on
community detection of bipartite
networks where this came from and so
really the idea here the key is takeaway
is that this a IJ tilde here is just a
binary matrix where there's a one if
snip I is connected to GJ and 0
otherwise and so for genes that are in
the or four nodes that are in the same
community together you asked if the link
between the snip and the gene if that
exists how likely is that to have
happened given the numb
of links that the snip has and the
number of links that the gene ends and
so you can do this and then there are
some good heuristics so since it's
technically an NP hard problem to to
maximize this modularity so we went
ahead and implemented that for our
bipartite network and what we did then
is we found that we got a really
strongly modular neck network so the
modularity value that we got out was
0.77 which is you know the modularity
goes between 0 & 1 we got 35 communities
and so a good sort of visual
representation of the the community
structure here is shown at the bottom
we're on the x axis you have snips on
the y axis you have genes and what we've
done is we've grouped all of the genes
together that are in the same community
and we've grouped all of the steps
together that are in the same community
as well and then each dot in this figure
represents a link the colored links are
those that connect jeans and snips that
are in the same community and then the
black links the sort of off diagonal
links if you will are ones that connect
jeans and snips that are in different
communities and so you can see that most
of the links in the network go between
genes and snips that are in the same
community together so you can sort of
see that this idea of edge enrichment
and so we had 35 communities out and
this is just another way of looking at
it I call it a seashell plot but what
we've done is we've grouped all of the
nodes that are in the same community
together and those represent those are
the circles here and so you can see
again that there's a much higher density
of links within these circles then there
are that go between the circles and so
this is all well and good but what we'd
like to do then is asked what kind of
biological enrichment do we see in these
communities do that do these communities
reflect anything
interesting and so we did a standard go
enrichment and of the 35 communities
that we found 13 are enriched for go
terms with a p-value less than 5 times
10 to the minus 4 and a couple of others
cut-offs for the overlap and whatnot and
so just to kind of give you a flavor of
some the enrichment we found one that
was associated with a microtubule
organization cell cycle on centrosome
and in addition we found this community
30 which it is enriched for immune
response stress response and t-cell
simulation which in the context of COPD
makes sense as of one of the large
features defining COPD is this chronic
inflammation and so there's a strong
immune and inflammatory response in the
lung tissue which is where we where we
got our genotyping n gene expression and
then finally we we have this community
18 which is chromatin assembly DNA
confirmation change and nuclear zone
assembly and this includes the hist 1 a
family as well so there does seem to be
some some very interesting biology here
which someone makes content makes sense
in the context of our our lung tissue
but the other thing that we want to do
and ultimately address is linking snips
to function and since we have roughly
30,000 snips what we wanted to do is not
just make a flat list of snips which is
you know we have these snips in this
community and then you know try to do
some sort of Fisher's exact test or
hyper geometric what we'd like to do is
be able to rank the snips in the
communities by some sort of topological
to Paula G that is relevant so what we
tried to do is what we did here is
scored the snips by their modularity
contribution so if you remember from a
couple of slides back the modularity is
really the sum of network enrichment of
Lincoln Richmond
uh over all of the communities so what
we can do is back up sort of back out
and say what is the modularity of
community H and that's given here and so
you're just subsetting the nodes that
are in community h and then furthermore
you can ask how much did note i
contribute to the modularity of
community h and so we define this course
color as we call it Q I h which is just
the fraction of modularity that snip I
contributes to community H of which it
is a part and so a sort of hand waving
or intuitive argument is that if you
look at this this community structure on
the left here with the red node and the
Blue Note you might say that the red
node is much more central to community
three because it has five links all of
which go to other nodes within community
three whereas the blue node which has
three links to other nodes in community
three also has a link going to community
too so our intuition would be to say
well clearly the red node is more
central to the community three structure
and that's really sort of the idea
behind our course for however we we
still need to figure out whether or not
these scores correlate or reflect any
sort of known biology so what we did is
we took a 259 disease-associated snips
from the NHGRI G West catalogs which of
all the nhgri gos catalogue snips and
then asked which of those are also eqtls
in our network and so we found 259 snips
that were also jiwa snips from the
catalog and then what we want to do is
ask what distribution of course cores do
our jiwa snips have and is that
significantly larger than for the non
jiwa snips so um we did this we tested
this in in two ways one we compute
KS test statistic where we asked whether
or not the distribution of jiwa score
scores is larger than the non-jewish
core scorers and then we did a
permutation test where we shuffled the
labels and we did this a hundred
thousand times and so the figure you're
looking at here is just the distribution
in blues the histogram of KS test scores
for the random shuffling and then the
the red dot here shows the true KS test
score for our jiwa snips versus the
others and then we also did a similar
wilcoxon test and so you can see for
both of them that the the p-value from
these tests the permutation p-value was
is 10 to the minus 5 and that's because
we ran 10 to the five tests and so in
addition to that we looked at the median
core score for our qo snips and asked
how much larger that is for the
non-jewish snips and it turns out that
the median course score for the gy snips
is 1.7 times higher than the median for
the non-jew escape so they do seem to be
more likely to be at the cores of these
communities the jiwa snips do uh in
addition we sort of looked at the
communities of which these jiwa snips
were apart and it turns out that 21 of
the 35 communities in our network had at
least one jiwa snip and we look then a
little bit at the function and we found
that this community 31 for example had
jiwa snips for COPD biomarkers smoking
behavior asthma we also looked at
community 30 which also had jiwa snips
for COPD mark biomarkers pulmonary
function interstitial lung disease which
is is also a sort of inflammation lung
disease and I would remind you that so
community 30 also had go term enrichment
for genes associated with T cell
stimulation inflammation and so on and
then community 18 here was also had
Jewish snips for psoriasis Crohn's
disease and cytokine response so we
think that this this approach to g wasps
which is to look at the expression and
the genotyping a due to eqtl analysis
and then ask you know instead of just
restricting our list so that we can make
sense of you the top 10 eqtls rather we
want to embrace the complexity of this
data and allow allow it to to reflect
the pattern of connectivity so a couple
of conclusions we think that by partek
networks are flexible way to handle
large numbers of eqtls and as the the
gtex program consortium continues to
grow and ramp up and as the availability
of whole genome sequencing and RNA seek
as those prices continue to fall which
john talked about a little bit the
falling prices of some of these assays
as those become readily available we
think the number of eqtls that are going
to be available to detect and and
compute it's going to grow and i think
this is a nice method to incorporate all
of those and to allow this sort of
agglomeration of weak signals that
points to biological function we also
found that community clustering can
highlight groups of biological elements
that are working together which we
showed from the the go enrichment and
also in the G wasps function and then
surprisingly we found that the Geo snips
our local but not global eqtl hubs and
that they often lie at the cores of
these communities and so some future
work we're thinking about integrating
epigenetic information for example
layering on encode data from the
relevant cell lines there's been some
work showing that looking at DNA
sensitivity can really inform some of
the eqtls in addition we're interested
in looking at the effects of methylation
on some of these eqtls particularly in
the context of co
e which is has a you know strong impact
from smoking which can affect
methylation and then we're also
interested in replicating these eqtls in
another lung data set and also comparing
the healthy networks with our disease
networks and I think that's another one
of the the advantages of computing these
core scorers is that it then allows for
distributions to be compared against
each other so you can ask you know which
are the most significant snips in the
disease network based on the core
scorers and then compare that with the
healthy eqtl network from lung and asked
whether or not those those snips
prioritized by the core scorers in the
disease case are also prioritized in
healthy case or it seems to be
differential between them and so with
that I'd like to thank my collaborators
peak Castaldi don de mayo Michael Cho
Craig Hirsch ed silverman all of whom
are at Brigham and Women's and the
Harvard Medical School and then some of
the other folks in the Quackenbush lab
marika cooler Kimberly glass and Albert
young and so thank you for your
attention I'd be happy to take any
questions oh and also my email is in the
bottom here J Platt at Jimmy harvard.edu
so thanks well thank you dr. platique
for that very informative presentation
before we start the Q&A session I'd like
to remind our audience that you can
submit your questions in the Q&A box
that will find by clicking on the green
Q&A button in the lower left hand corner
of the presentation window we'll try to
answer all the questions we can and
we'll wait a minute to see if anybody
has any questions at this point in the
meantime I'd like to remind everybody
that this presentation will be available
for replay for six months after the days
of the slide presentation and we have a
question here this is from
and as did rich from the Institute /
systems biology do the eqtl hub snips
tend to have lower allele frequency from
the bullet hole analogy wouldn't want to
expect strong negative selection on
these snips so yes I think that's a
that's an excellent question I agree
that that I think you you would expect a
strong negative selection on the snips
that are significantly affecting gene
expression in a way that is that is
altering that is altering the function
of the cell so I think you know in the
context of these hubs we're still trying
to investigate you know what exactly
that is whether or not it's it's a
function of statistical association or
it maybe it's just some sort of kind of
neutral evolution that it's it's not
deleterious and so it's not swept away
it may not be functional even though its
associated so yeah thanks okay well once
again I'd like to remind everyone that
looked for an email from lab Rhodes
reminding you when this broadcast will
be available for replay and we invite
you to forward that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event once again thank you for joining
us today and we'll see you next time you
buy